- I go out on my dock at
night, up north where I am now
and it's dark
and the expanse of the
heavens is laid out above me.
And I look up, well, I'm not
thinking religious thoughts.
I'm confronting the
infinite itself,
and that moves you inside.
And I would say it even
moves you to imitation
because you know what it means
to have your head in the stars.
Right?
It means to be oriented up in
the highest possible manner.
And so, we're so
compelled to imitate,
again, at an instinctual
level that we can even imitate
the infinite that we see a
spread above us in the night sky
and that's a religious calling.
And all this talk about
whether you believe in God,
it's all propositionalised.
It's like...
Well, it misses the point.
That's why I don't ever
answer when people say,
"Do you believe in God?"
I say, "What do you
mean by believe?"
And they think, "Well,
you know what I mean?"
It's like, no, you don't
know what you mean.
You have a bunch of assumptions
that you don't even recognize
that you're peppering
the question with
to force me into a box
to deliver the kind of answer
that your question demands
given the way you phrased it.
It's like, no.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me
today is an author,
a lecturer, a psychologist,
and the world's
preeminent lobster expert,
Jordan Peterson, my old friend.
Welcome back to
the Rubin Report.
- Hi, Dave.
So good to see you and
to be doing this again.
- All right, here we go again.
We've done this a
couple of times.
I thought we'll do it a
little differently this time
instead of just me tossing
you up for some questions.
If we did a little
kind of push and pull
and churn through
some of these ideas,
but I guess where we start
first is, you're in Toronto.
I'm in Los Angeles.
We live in places that are
seemingly really out of touch
with a lot of the
things we talk about.
People ask me about that a lot.
How's life in Toronto right now.
- Well, in relationship
to the COVID restrictions,
I talked to a senior advisor
to one of the
provincial governments
a couple of weeks ago.
He told me flat out that
the COVID policy here
is driven by nothing
but opinion polls
related to the popularity
of the government,
no science, no end game
in sight, no real plan.
And so what that means is that
part of the population
that's most afraid of COVID,
I know it's what,
50% of Democrats believe
that you have a 50% shot at
getting hospitalized
if you catch COVID
and 25% of Republicans.
And so I suspect it's
similar in Canada.
And so, policy is being driven
by people who are more afraid
than they should be,
and it was a very
disheartening conversation
because I trust this guy
and he knows what
he's talking about.
And so,
I wouldn't say I'm cynical
about governments exactly
because cynicism is,
it's a cheap shortcut to
approximating wisdom, let's say,
and you have to be judicious
in your criticisms.
But I still found that
extremely disheartening
because I thought at
least policies that
I don't agree with,
the restrictive policies
were at least driven by
something remotely resembling
a scientifically informed plan
and he was irate at
what had been happening,
enough to consider resigning.
So it's pretty appalling.
- So what does that tell
you at a psychological level
about fear in general?
If this isn't driven by science
and people hear
things on the media
and then suddenly
they say, "Okay, yes.
please lock me in my house.
Please keep me in
a mask forever.
Please keep me not going to
holidays with my family."
Just psychologically,
has that unearthed anything
that maybe you thought
wasn't as intense?
- Well, I think
the thing that surprised
me the most probably was
how rapidly we stampeded to
imitate a totalitarian state
in the immediate aftermath
of the release of COVID.
Now, if you think it
through a little bit,
no one really knew how serious
the virus was going to be
and so it was an unknown threat.
And so you can imagine a herd
of animals or a school of fish
for that matter, because this
kind of phenomena is universal
throughout the animal kingdom.
The cost of overreacting to
a threat is generally minimal
compared to under-reacting
to a real threat, right?
Overreacting to a
hypothetical threat is cheap
compared to under-reacting
to an actual threat
'cause if you under
react, you can die.
Whereas if you overreact,
you generally just get
tired for a minute.
So a hurdle stampede,
because the most neurotic
member of the herd jumps first,
and then they'll
instantly follow them
and that's kind of what we did
in the early stages
of the pandemic.
The Chinese acted first.
Now, unfortunately,
they are a totalitarian
state and we all followed.
And that's excusable
in some sense
because we didn't know what
sort of threat we were facing.
But then the breakdown...
It's really appalling in Canada,
the breakdown of our rights,
let's say, for mobility,
for freedom of
speech, et cetera,
it's particular to grating to
me in the Canadian context.
Because way back in the '80s,
Prime Minister, Pierre Trudeau,
our current Prime
Minister's father
who was quite an intellectual,
he was very enamored
of French civil law,
and he grafted a bill
of rights on top of the
Canadian federal common
law structure, essentially
and I didn't like that at all.
I thought that was
a bastardization
of a great English
common law tradition.
I'm not a fan of bills of rights
because they're predicated
on the idea that
you have a finite set of rights
and that the social
contract awards them to you
or the government and I
think that's backwards.
It's like, you have all
the rights there are,
except those that are
expressly forbidden
by detailed legislation
that mostly was generated
from the bottom up, that's the
English common law tradition.
Anyways, everybody celebrated
the bill of rights,
you're protected,
Oh my God, all our rights
are protected now forever.
It was Pierre Trudeau's major
accomplishment hypothetically.
Now we have his
son and it's like,
"Yeah, what's it good for?"
My father isn't vaccinated.
He decided not to partly because
they were telling him he had to,
and he has his other reasons.
I have family members
who aren't vaccinated
for health reasons who
also had COVID twice
and didn't really feel they
needed to be vaccinated again.
In any case, it's
extraordinarily annoying
to see this happening
and to then find out that
there's nothing behind it except
the most instrumental and
cowardly random polling
is extremely disheartening
and also maddening
and also angering all
of those things at once.
- Do you think it's possible
that the polling is
out of whack too?
- Of course it is.
- I mean, you've been doing
polling forever, right?
I mean, this is one of
the things that, yeah.
- Of course it's out
of whack, Jesus Christ.
I mean, how do you get
accurate polling data?
Well, okay, over what timeframe?
You're gonna poll every day?
How about every hour?
How about every minute,
every week, every two weeks?
Who answers the phone calls
when you do the polls?
How did you construct
the questions?
Are you eliciting a
particular kind of answer
because you paid
insufficient attention
to the way the
question was posed?
Et cetera, et cetera.
So it's not guidance
from the polls.
It's a quasi
informed random walk
which is a lot easier
than thinking it through.
But to see that happening
in spite of the much vaunted
protection for our rights,
Canadians who aren't
vaccinated now
cannot leave the country.
- Yeah.
- Like what the hell?
Why is that?
And I'm...
Look, I got vaccinated and
people took me to task for that
and I thought, "All right,
I'll get the vaccine.
Here's the deal, guys.
I'll get the vaccine, you
fucking leave me alone."
And did that work?
No.
So, stupid me.
That's how I feel about it.
It's like, well now I have
to get tested for COVID
when I come back into Canada.
I have to get tested
before I leave Canada.
Now, that might be
the latter issue.
That's an issue
with the Americans
and so that's outside
of the Canadian purview,
but the restrictions
to get back into Canada
are even more stringent.
It's like, "Why get
the vaccine then
if you're not going
to leave me alone?"
And I don't think the
evidence that unvaccinated
or that vaccinated people are
less contagious, let's say,
I don't think it's
very compelling.
- [Rubin] Yeah.
- So why are the unvaccinated
all of a sudden a danger?
And I certainly don't
understand the push
to get children vaccinated.
I think that's
absolutely reprehensible
and I also can't figure out.
Norman Doidge wrote
a piece in Tablet
called "Needle Points."
And one of the things
he pointed out was that
if you take the top 25
least trusted institutions,
in that group,
the most distrusted
institutions include Big Pharma
and for good reason.
And he details out the lawsuits
that Big Pharma has had to pay
because of misbehavior
on their part,
broadly speaking multiple
companies over the last 20 years
and they're the biggest
lawsuits in American history,
which is really saying something
because your court
system is set up
so that big lawsuits
are really possible.
- [Rubin] Right.
- And so I see
that the leftists,
all of a sudden it's like,
"Big Pharma, yeah, trust them."
It's like, what?
What?
Really?
You guys, this is...
I don't understand that at all.
And psychologically...
So what's going on here?
It's like, well,
I think the underlying
phenomenon is something like
well, as long as it's
for health and safety,
it's always good.
And not to get
conspiratorial here,
but the same damn thing
is going to happen
with the climate change push.
- [Rubin] Absolutely.
- Absolutely.
- They're already re...
It's already being
reconfigured as,
well, it's the biggest public
health issue of our time.
It's like, no, I don't think so.
I think overreaching bureaucrats
are the biggest health,
What would you say?
The biggest challenge to
our health of our time
and I think that's especially
true of the COP26 bunch.
The Chinese just announced
today, I believe it was today,
they're building 150
new nuclear actors.
Like not one, 150,
and we can't get our act
together in the States,
and Canada for that
matter to build like one
and in California,
they're gonna shut, what?
10% of the power there down.
It's like, no nuclear.
Well, what are we
gonna replace it with?
Wind.
Yeah, well only if
we put windmills
in front of the politicians
pushing for wind.
Can you imagine how
much wind it would take
to blow your car down the road?
So it's so...
And so if those people
at the climate change
summit were serious,
what they would be
and we could be very
very specific about this.
Here's what you do
if you're a leftist
who's concerned
about the environment
and the poor
simultaneously, okay?
You may power energy as cheap
as possible for everyone
because there's no difference
between energy and wealth,
and because rich people
can't hoard energy.
It's not a Prieto
problem, right?
Because all the energy doesn't
end up in the hands of a few.
So you try to build
nuclear reactors perhaps,
there's a bit of a problem
getting rid of the waste
and there's a lot
of bureaucratic
wrangling around that.
It's not a solved
problem entirely,
but we don't have
a better option
than nuclear in the long run,
and so you make power
as cheap as possible.
So if you wanna
save the climate,
you wanna make power
everywhere in the world
as cheap as possible,
as fast as possible
to make people as
rich as possible
because the richer they get,
the more they care
about the environment
and that pattern is
clear in China and India
which have greened substantially
in the last 20 years.
Those two countries
have greened in area
the size of the Amazon
in the last 20 years,
and that's an addition by the
way, just so everyone knows.
Here's a cool little fact,
you know that as carbon
dioxide levels rise,
plants can grow in drier
environment, drier environments,
semi-arid like deserts,
like the sand banks
on oceans and lakes,
stabilizing that as well.
And so because the carbon
dioxide levels have risen,
the plants can close their
pores, the breathing pores
and so they don't
evaporate water as much,
and so an area the size
of Alaska has greened
in the last couple of decades
in addition to what China
and India have planted.
And so...
I worked for the UN
Secretary General's Committee
on Sustainable Development
and to some degree COP26
is an attempt to bring
the corporate world
in line with those
developmental goals.
And there was a bunch of
problems with the project
'cause there were 200
goals and that's too many.
You have to prioritize them
and no one was willing
to accept beyond Lomborg
and that's a different
conversation.
But what I learned,
'cause I read about
200 books at that time
on the environment and
sustainable development
and what I learned was
things are way better
than anybody thinks.
We have a glorious future in
front of us if we want to.
The best way to save the planet
is to make poor people rich
as fast as we possibly can.
So that means we can have
our cake and eat it too,
and isn't that
absolutely lovely?
And the biggest environmental
issue that's facing us,
isn't global warming, it's
overfishing in the oceans,
as far as I'm concerned
because that's that we
could actually stop.
It's actually extremely damaging
and we know how to stop it.
And Trudeau to his
credit, by the way,
has produced a series of
marine protected areas
along Canada's coastline
that weren't there before.
Now, I don't know how
protected they are
and how thorough
that legislation is,
but that's something that
he's done that actually counts
as a credible accomplishment
in my estimation.
- So-
- But...
Go ahead, Dave.
- Well, first off,
I've interviewed Bjorn
a couple of times
but his last book
basically illustrates,
I mean, it's mostly
illustrations
that lay out almost
everything you're saying here.
So I just want people to
know you're not making it up.
We'll link to that interview
so they can see it, but-
- No, no.
- yeah, go ahead.
- Okay, so well look,
so there's these 200 development
goals and sustainable,
it's like, okay, well what
does sustainable mean?
And over what timeframe?
That's actually incredibly
complicated, right?
Because timeframe
is a real problem.
Do we mean sustainable
over 5,000 years?
Well, why should we care?
Because God only knows what
the world is gonna be like
in 5,000 years.
Just look at what computer
technology is doing,
we can't plan out that far.
So that's probably too long.
Hundred years?
Well, we're all dead then.
And you might think,
well, we should care.
It's like, yeah, perhaps,
but how should we care?
'Cause we can't
predict that far out.
So the timeframe
is really crucial.
And then the fact that
there are 200 goals,
that's like zero goals.
Like if you were trying to
do 200 things, first of all,
at any moment, you wouldn't
be able to do anything
because at any moment
you can only do one thing
and so you have to prioritize.
And I asked repeatedly when I
was working on this committee,
why aren't these
goals prioritized?
And the answer was,
"Well, they all have
separate constituencies
who are fighting for
that particular value
and they get annoyed if there's
any sequential approach."
It's like, okay, well, that
just means we do nothing
because 200 goals is just chaos.
And then I found Lomborg.
And so what Lomborg does is,
he hires teams of economists
to assess the goals
in a given country or
globally for that matter
by cost benefit.
And you can argue about that
because there's assumptions
that you have to use
that are built into
your analysis, right?
There's always priority axioms
and prejudices and biases
and so forth and constraints,
but he does it with 10
different teams of economists.
So that's kind of good,
and then he averages across the
whole set of the economists.
And then you might say,
"Well, it's an economic analysis
and that doesn't take
everything into account."
It's like a, everything
can't be taken into account.
And b, do you have
a better idea?
And if not, then, "Well,
what good is your criticism?"
Like, I, haven't seen a better
idea than Lomborg's idea,
but from anyone.
- Is part of the
problem that people,
because our institutions have
in so many ways failed us
and I know you've
obviously talked about it
and wrote about it
in your last book
that we shouldn't just
needlessly wanna burn down
these institutions.
But they've sort of
failed us to the point
that when they do
these conferences,
like these climate conferences,
I was listening to
Obama's speech yesterday
and he's going on and on about
how we're gonna have to
sacrifice and all that.
Meanwhile, he just spoke of-
- Yeah, who is gonna
have to sacrifice?
Who is gonna have to sacrifice?
And exactly what?
- $15 million house.
He just bought a $15
million house on the water
in Martha's vineyard.
I was just down in
Miami, trust me,
there's plenty of
$40 million mansions.
- Well, that's a sacrifice.
Well, there you go, Dave.
That's a sacrifice
because he didn't buy
a $40 million mansion.
(laughs)
- Right, so we should be
thankful for him as he flew in.
- Well, so, let's
talk about sacrifice.
- But yeah, what
about that break down?
- Yeah, okay.
So yeah, let's let the old
people freeze in the dark.
That's what's gonna
happen in Europe
if we get a cold winter.
So who's gonna sacrifice here?
Well, I can tell you
the answer to that
and let's play leftist
here for a minute, okay?
So there are hierarchies,
and I think they're
competence hierarchies
but they're corrupted
by power to some degree.
And how much is worthy
of investigation
and we should always
clean them up.
I mean, you just did
that in some sense
when you said our institutions
are corrupt, right?
And we have to be very
judicious, which institutions?
Where are they corrupt?
How are they corrupt?
Add a level of detail
and analyzed in a manner
that allows us to fix them
instead of replace
them wholesale, right?
So, okay.
In any case, in a hierarchy,
when there's stress,
illness and death climb
from the bottom up.
That's partly why you wanna
be near the top in a hierarchy
'cause it's actually
psychophysiological easier.
Well, obviously
'cause otherwise, why
would you strive for?
There are other reasons,
maybe you want to do do
good for other people,
maybe you're motivated by power,
maybe you're a psychopath,
maybe you're acting
instrumentally,
there's lots of other reasons.
But one of the
consequences of success
is that you don't die.
So who dies first?
Well, as soon as you
stress the system,
let's say we double
energy prices.
Well, who's gonna sit...
What's the sacrifice?
Well, old poor people
'cause they're more
susceptible to see death
when they can't afford
air conditioning,
when they can't afford heat.
And so, yeah,
but there's too many people
on the planet anyway.
So what the hell we
kill a few, whatever.
They're just poor people.
And this is the thing
that bugs me so much.
It's like, "Okay, leftists,
which side are you on here?
It's like, "Are you
gonna, sacrifice the poor
to your hypothetical
future utopia?"
"Yeah, but they're
all gonna die anyways,
because the planet
is gonna burn."
No, it's not.
The IPCC never said that.
So Bjorn has modeled
out a reasonable amount
of climate change in
meaning temperature increase
over the next hundred years,
he's taken what's promoted
as the scientific consensus.
There is no
consensus in science.
That's not how science works.
It's not a consensus enterprise.
But nonetheless, he's
playing along with it.
Okay, we'll take your figures.
It's gonna produce
somewhat of a detriment
in global economic growth but
growth is about 4% a year.
And so even if that
declines a chunk
because of global warming,
everyone's still gonna be
like five times as rich
as they are now
in a hundred years
if we don't screw things up
and so maybe they'll
be four times as rich.
Well, that's a cost
and fair enough,
and if we can ameliorate it,
we should probably try not to
change natural environments
any faster than
we have to, right?
Because of unexpected
consequences.
It's a reasonable argument.
But here's another
thing, this net zero.
Okay, as soon as you hear
someone say anything like that,
zero, you know,
they're not thinking.
- It's like zero
tolerance for drugs.
- You mean we can't get
COVID deaths to zero?
We shouldn't be trying to
get COVID deaths to zero?
- Yeah, right, exactly.
Exactly.
Well, and we don't have
zero tolerance for drugs.
Zero is the wrong number.
Zero pollution.
Well, no.
You know, cows, there's
manure from cows,
people go to the bathroom.
There's not zero pollution.
So net zero, it's an
empty talking point
to put up a flag that
you're on the right side.
It's not differentiated,
careful, thoughtful,
thorough detail
oriented thinking
at the level that will
actually produce solutions.
And there's no
discussion about like,
what are we aiming at here?
Well, how about copious
energy for everyone
as clean as possible?
But in that order.
Copious energy for everyone,
lowest possible price,
resilient stable systems.
And to their credit,
the Democrats
and their Infrastructure Bill
are building resilience goals
in relationship to the power
grid and that's necessary
because we should
be stress testing
those systems constantly.
But if you're on the left and
you care about poor people,
the only thing you should really
care about is cheap energy.
And why is that?
Let's be very precise
about this, okay?
What makes people
prosperous and secure?
Work.
What is work?
It is the expenditure of energy.
What is energy?
Work.
What is work?
Wealth.
You wanna deal with
absolute poverty
or even relative
poverty for that matter,
energy is everything.
And here's another fact.
So you Americans have actually
knocked your carbon
dioxide output down
14% in the last
couple of decades.
You know why?
Fracking.
'Cause it made natural gas cheap
and replaced dirtier
forms of energy.
Plus it made you way
less reliant on OPEC
and the Russians.
And how is that not good
for planetary stability?
You talk about the environment,
how about not a third world war?
'Cause that's not so
good for the environment.
And so fracking knocked carbon
dioxide output in the U.S.
down 14%.
Who would have predicted that?
And in Shellenberger's
book, "Apocalypse Never,"
he interviewed an MIT
scientist and he said,
you really wanna knock
carbon dioxide output down,
make India and China,
but India, he was speaking
of more particularly,
switch to coal as
fast as possible.
You think, coal?
Why?
Oh, it's better than wood.
And we know the pattern,
wood, that's not so good.
You'd cut down trees,
you cut down forest,
it's really polluting,
especially indoors
and that kills a
lot of people's,
stunts a lot of
children's growth,
growth in the broad sense
'cause indoor pollution
is much more deadly
than outdoor pollution,
generally speaking.
So, and wood, well, you
have to cut down forests.
It's inefficient,
it puts particulates in
the atmosphere as well.
So you switch to coal.
Coal is better.
It's not wood, to begin with.
And then it's not
near as polluting
and coal technologies
have got quite clean.
Now you still have
to mine the coal
and there's an
environmental cost for that.
Well, then you switch
from coal to natural gas.
Natural gas is pretty damn good.
There's lots of it, it's
plentiful, it's clean.
And then maybe, if we
can get our act together
and have some sense,
we could switch from
natural gas to fusion.
Well, and then we could
have energy for everyone
at the lowest possible cost.
And then what happens?
Well, people get rich.
They care about the environment.
So how is that not
the right solution to,
let's not call it climate
change because that's annoying.
It's like, let's not produce
any more waste than we have to
while we try to live.
Fair enough, you know.
That's a reasonable goal.
But all I see coming out
of these COP26 conferences,
that sort of thing is,
here's a bunch of people doing
it wrong and let stop them.
It's like, yeah,
yeah, right guys.
Why don't you try to
do something instead?
- Okay, that's exactly where
I wanted to go with this.
Are we just at the point
where the machinery,
the institutions,
the media tech,
the whole machinery of how
we communicate to each other
has broken down
to the point that
if everything you
said right there,
you stepped into an office
and you were sitting down
with all of those
people, or even just AOC
and the people here that
want The Green New Deal,
and you laid all that out that
they will basically just say-
- No, I don't think.
- "Well, okay, good for him.
He's got some studies."
- No, I don't believe that.
I don't believe that.
- Yeah?
- I think we have
to be judicious
in our institutional criticisms.
Well, there's a bunch
of reasons for that.
First of all, that
infrastructure bill
that was just passed,
that's nowhere near as
stupid as it could have been.
And if you look at the
White House messaging,
well, that's
something, isn't it?
- Yeah, it's something.
- It's something, man.
- Yeah.
- And if you look at the
White House messaging,
it's about 2% diversity,
inclusivity and equity
and that's not too bad 'cause
zero is asking for too much,
as we already discussed.
And I've talked to
lots of Democrats
and lots of Republicans and
there are people of goodwill
who are competent on both
sides and they're trying.
Well, people don't understand.
So your congressmen federally.
All right, so I
went to Washington
and I talked to a whole bunch
of them trying to find out.
I read this book a long time
ago and called, "Systemantics."
It's a great book by John Gall.
It's a great book,
"Systemantics."
One of its dictums is,
the system does not do
what its name says it does.
And so then the question
is, what does it do?
Well, then you have to look.
So I worked at Social Services
for the Alberta government
when I was a kid.
And social services,
what do they do?
Well, I was tasked weirdly
enough when I was about 19
to find out, to update a
big consulting company's
analysis of spending of the
Social Services Department.
They had paid them some
hundreds of thousands of dollars
and I was just working
as a summer intern
and they said, "Update this."
And I thought, "Huh, okay."
And so I phoned around
trying to get the figures
and no one knew what they were.
The system had no idea where
the money it was spending went.
So I was trying
to get stats like,
how much of the
welfare money spent
actually goes to recipients?
Couldn't find the data.
And then I realized, okay,
social services,
what does it do?
Probably spends 95% of
its money on bureaucrats
who are implementing
social service programs.
And then I thought,
"Well, should I be
cynical about that?"
It's like, well, no.
It's actually hard
to distribute money,
and if 5% of it
goes to its target,
that might not be too bad.
It's not great by the way
but it's better than running
at a deficit or zero.
And so many charities
are like that.
If they get 10%
to the recipients,
they're doing pretty well.
And you can be
cynical about that.
So in any case, when I went
to Washington, I thought,
"Okay, these are
Congress people.
What do they do?"
Well, hypothetically,
they analyze policy,
they set out strategy, they
talk to their constituents.
No, they spend 25 hours
a week fundraising.
25 hours a week, both sides.
They can't do it in their
congressional offices
'cause that's illegal.
So they have other offices in
these industrial warehouses
with drop ceilings
and they basically are
telemarketers 25 hours a week.
Well, how the hell can those
people get anything done?
And then I had lunches where
there was some Democrats
and some Republicans,
generally more junior members
just trying to get
to know each other
and I had them go
around the table
and say why they went
into public service
and you couldn't have
asked for more patriotic,
heartfelt declarations
of virtuous intent.
And you couldn't tell the
Democrats from the Republicans,
not on the basis of that.
And then you say,
"Well, why did they
fundraise 25 hours a week?"
Well they have to be
elected every two years?
And then the party apparatus
because they don't really know
how to spend money effectively,
communicating with people to
get them to vote for them.
They think money will do it.
They won't support them
unless they raise a
certain amount of money.
Well, how the hell can
those people do their job?
And so will you sit down
and you talk to them
and the vast majority of them,
they're even self-sacrificing.
It's not a job I would want.
There isn't a lot
of security in it.
If you're competent, you
could go do something else
and be paid more and be
harassed a hell of a lot less.
They're trying.
And when you lay out
the sorts of arguments
that I'd be laying out,
I rarely talk to anyone
who's competent of goodwill
and I don't care whether on the
Democrat or Republican side,
that doesn't see
the logic in this.
And so what do we
gotta be aware of
on the conservative and
down on the leftist end is,
especially you guys
in the States is,
do not throw the baby
out with the bath water.
I went to New York city
here four days ago,
that's a great city.
You have a great country.
It's a work of art.
Don't screw it up with
fast style criticisms.
There are things wrong
because there always are,
but the devil is in
the details, man.
You got to do a
detailed analysis.
It's like, the leftists say,
"Well, the whole judicial
system is corrupt."
Well, what's the evidence?
Well, the disproportionate
incarceration rate.
It's like, that's a
fairly damning indictment.
Okay, where exactly
is it going wrong?
Exactly, precisely procedurally
so that we could fix it.
Well, the whole thing has
to be burned to the ground.
It's like, yeah, well, no
and you aren't thinking.
So you're not helpful.
And then you take a
problem like that apart,
the differential
incarceration rate.
Man, that's a rat's nest.
It's complicated, man.
You know it's tangled
up with slavery,
it's tangled up with Jim Crow,
it's tangled up with
differential exposure
to literacy in childhood.
It's tangled up with
single parent families,
violent communities, the
drug war, drug policy,
just to name a few.
Then we could say
whatever implicit
racism still exists
'cause that's not zero.
It's very, very complicated
and people don't want
a detailed on the ground
analysis of such problems.
What they wanna do
is label it with a low
resolution representation,
so like a one pixel
representation,
and then they
wanna contrast that
with the wrong one
pixel representation.
Then they wanna feel
the moral virtue
that they would have felt
if they had actually
solved the problem.
- So how fix the resolution?
And when I ask you this,
I include myself in this.
I'm talking about news
every day on the show,
I try to do it in the
most honest way possible.
Obviously I have my biases,
I'm not pretending that
I have no opinions.
But often when you get
bludgeoned over the head
with sort of the low
resolution stuff enough,
your resolution starts
getting screwed up.
So how do we arbitrage-
- Yeah.
- those two positions?
- Well, it's not
just bias, right?
It's not just bias.
It's also heuristics and
there's a difference.
Like a heuristic is a
functional simplification
and we use heuristics
all the time.
Like the image you see
of me as a heuristic
'cause you are not seeing me.
Well, first of
all, I'm not there.
Second of all, even
if you were seeing me,
if we were in person, you'd
still be seeing a heuristic
'cause you don't see
my subatomic structure.
You don't see my
cellular structure.
You don't see the context
that I'm embedded in.
You see an iconic image
that stands for the reality
that's too complex to perceive.
And so it's not easy to tell
when you're using an
appropriate heuristic
and the basic rule of thumb is
use the simplest
thumbnail you can use
that will get the job done.
Now the question is...
Then the question is,
well, what is the job?
And you have to ask yourself,
well, how much honor
moral superiority
are you actually striving for?
And the answer
generally is, a lot.
And that's how a heuristic
turns into a bias
and so it's partly ignorance.
Some of it's malevolence
and willful blindness,
but it's partly ignorance.
It's like, you just
don't know, right?
You don't even know
what you don't know.
And then you think,
well, isn't it interesting
that you have people
who will pontificate about
fixing the electrical system,
the power system,
who couldn't wire up a plugin
in their house and you think,
well, does that matter?
It's like, well, yes.
In some sense it does matter
because unless there's
a chain of causality built
from the highest
level abstractions
right down to the
power outlet itself,
the plan in some sense
is deeply flawed.
And then we have
another problem, David.
So look, when I worked
on this UN committee,
I was on the Canadian
subsection of the committee.
There was only one
Canadian subsection
and I was pulled in by
the man who ran that,
and I worked on it
for about two years
and I was serious about it
and I rewrote fair
chunks of that document,
the sustainable goals guide,
partly because it was
stuck in like 1985
with this old cold
war mentality.
It was terribly written.
So I just rewrote a bunch of it.
And what happened was,
a lot of those rewrites
stuck and that was shocking.
It's like, what the hell?
How did that happen?
And the answer was,
"Well, I did the work.
And in order for
someone to change it,
they would have
had to rewrite it."
And then you think,
well, why didn't they?
And the answer is, well,
they didn't really have time.
So these things
work in a weird way.
So this guide to
sustainable development
has become sort of
a centerpiece of,
I wouldn't say COP26 exactly,
but similar
large-scale endeavors
to sort of steer where
the planet is going.
Okay, so how was
that put together?
Well, the UN Secretary General
nominated a bunch
of ex-presidents and
ex-prime ministers,
like high end people, right?
But the thing about those
people is, they're busy.
Their days are scheduled.
It doesn't matter if
they're former presidents
or prime ministers,
their days are scheduled
to the minute for like 16 hours.
Well, they don't
have time to sit and
analyze
the sustainable
development goals.
So then it falls down the
hierarchy of bureaucracy
until it lands on the desk
of someone who actually
either wants to, or
has time to do it.
And God only knows
how many tiers down
it has to fall before
that person takes it on.
And then are they
trained to do this?
Well, no.
The only person I know
that's trained to do it
would be Lomborg.
And he doesn't have
the expertise necessary
to really do it,
but he's still the
one I would say
knows better than
anyone broadly speaking,
that I've met.
And it's not like we
have training schools to
prepare people, to
prepare documents
on sustainable
development over the next
100 years for the planet,
it requires so much expertise.
And so these things
are cobbled together,
and it's not even
that conspiracy,
you don't have to
pause the conspiracy.
Now ideas can take on a
conspiratorial
formal by themselves,
this is no conspiracy.
It's so badly done that
it's quite frightening.
- So then where would you piece
the algorithmic part of this,
the tech part that then
you have a bunch of people
that are not quite
qualified to be,
well, they can be
discussing it, but perhaps
analyzing it or giving
the policy prescriptions
that are constantly fighting
about these things all day,
and then keeping a whole
bunch of other people
in a perpetual state
of confusion or fear.
I mean, that's the piece
of this that emerged
just in the last 20
years, that seems to
hide the rest of it,
it sits higher in that
hierarchy than the rest of it.
- Okay, I need more specificity.
So what do you mean exactly?
Are you talking about
the political battles
around this sort of thing, or?
- I'm talking about
the political battles,
I'm talking about the
cultural battles, all of it.
The stuff that, that
generates the clicks
that keeps us all
watching things,
looking at our phones.
- Well, oh, I see what you mean.
- Often is done by
a class of people,
that are not the ones that
you're saying should be
sort of analyzing
this stuff properly.
- Well, okay,
let's look at what the
tech companies are doing.
Well, let's play angels
advocate for a minute.
Okay, they are really
trying to deliver you
something you will attend to,
they really are
trying to do that.
And they are
building unbelievably
powerful AI machines
to analyze even your
bloody eye movements
to see what you're looking at.
And you think, oh my God,
that's scary, it's like,
yes and no.
They are also trying to
figure out what you want,
and need and deliver it to
you as fast as possible.
Amazon click bang (table
bangs) at your doorstep.
Yeah, okay, well, they
know a lot about you,
but it turns out you
actually have to know
a lot about someone in
order to be able to do that.
So can we trust them?
Can we trust us?
Well, not if we're lying.
That's the critical issue here.
It's not even ideology, exactly,
although we could get into that.
It's lying that
corrupts all of this,
that turns a
heuristic into a bias,
that turns information
into misinformation.
And so these companies
that are trying to serve us
to the degree that
there's deceit,
and let's say the naked
for power and control
as kind of a psychopathic edge
to the degree that
that's operative,
all these systems
get contaminated,
and we definitely have to
be on the lookout for that.
But we can't demonize
the corporations,
the tech corporations
in the same way.
I mean, look what we're doing.
I'm 3000 miles away from you,
and you and I are having
a conversation that
a million people
are going to watch
that we can publish
in five minutes,
and that it'll be distributed
like a book used to be
instantly.
It's like my God,
what a miracle?
And here's another miracle.
This is something, man.
So I have these
teams of translators
working on my YouTube content.
That's been put together
by a very diligent team who
have familiarized
themselves in 13 languages
with the idiom of the languages.
It's not Google translate.
It's proved very
hard to take English,
YouTube content, let's
say video content
and translate it
to other languages.
Because it hasn't been
thought through
carefully enough.
And this is particular
been the case
for my Russian translation team.
And so three weeks ago,
I talked to my head
Russian translator,
who I hadn't met
before, very bright guy.
And we had a real
time conversation
because Zoom has now
enabled a feature.
So if you have a
simultaneous translator,
it'll suppress the Russian
and only let you
hear the English.
And so now with a
real time translator,
I can talk to
anyone in the world.
And then I can record that.
I mean, this is a
technological Marvel that's
unparalleled, it's unbelievable,
it's just like one thing
that Zoom added as a feature,
in the last couple of months.
This over Simplification and
demonization, this has to stop.
Here's something horrible.
I talked to Andy Noah yesterday.
Okay, and I said, "Look, I
talked to a bunch of Democrats,
influential Democrats
about Antifa,
and they said,
'Antifa is illusory.'
And I thought, 'Okay,
you believe that.'.
But you believe there's
a conspiratorial force
that's very power powerful
on the right, that's real.
Okay, so they believe that,
but they don't believe
Antifa is real."
So we give the devil his due.
Well, what do you
mean real, exactly?
Okay, so I asked Andy
Noah, who's been like half,
he's been beat mostly
to death twice,
and been severely hurt twice
while reporting on this.
He's a brave guy.
I said, "Well, these
lefties, the moderates,
these are reasonable
people I'm talking to.
They're certainly people who
are as morally good as me,
let's say, so,
what do they mean,
is it illusory?"
Well, I said, "Well,
how many actually organized
Antifa groups are they?
Organized, so there's
identifiable group
with identifiable people,
they're kind of working
full time on this.
They have a leader,
they have a website,
you can point to them."
He figured maybe 20.
I said, "Well, how many
people do you think
in each of those groups are
committed to the Antifa ethos,
whatever that is fascist,
anarchist, left-wing,
paramilitary,
like who the hell
are these people?
Are they left or right,
or does that matter,
or maybe they're a
weird mixture of both
and it's to their advantage
to have the left
think they're right
and the right think they're left
because really what
they're after is chaos?"
And that could
easily be the case,
in fact, I'm sure
it is the case.
He figured, "Oh, maybe in
each of those groups there's
20 to 30 people, 40 maybe,
so there's like 800 of them."
Okay, so that means they
don't exist in some sense.
So if you took a city,
the size of Halifax,
which isn't a big
city, but it's a city,
there'd be one guy like
that in the whole city.
So does it exist?
Well,
not really, it's
not an organization.
He talked about Rose City
Antifa as the sort of
epicenter of this trouble.
But here's what
we're really facing,
it isn't left wing radicals
who are trying to
take over cities,
that's a way of looking at it.
It's agents of chaos,
in whose interest it is
to sow discord as
thoroughly as possible.
And then the question is,
well, in this age of
interconnectedness,
how do we protect ourselves?
We, Republicans and
Democrats alike,
the 95% of people who make
up the reasonable middle,
how do we protect
ourselves against
800 malevolent psychopaths?
And that's the endless
question of the human race.
So I wanna spin something off
sideways from that
just momentarily.
Men are less
agreeable than women.
It's a reliable
personality difference.
It's only about 60-40,
so if you picked a man
and a woman out of a crowd
and you tried to figure out
who was least agreeable,
if you bet on the man, you'd
be right 60% of the time.
That's not that much,
but it's not nothing.
It means all the really
disagreeable people are men,
right?
Out of the extremes.
Okay, so,
and women actually
like disagreeable men
more than agreeable men.
So there's a preference,
which is why we're like that
because women are powerful
agents of sexual selection
and they decide that that's how
disagreeable men should be.
Why?
Okay, so here's the
trade off, right?
The more disagreeable you are,
the less empathic
and compassionate
and polite you are.
So in some sense,
the less generous,
the less concerned with others,
the more concerned with
yourself and your victories.
Okay, so why would
women pick men
who are more
disagreeable than them?
Well, that's the beauty and
the beast problem in some part.
Right?
Now, so you want a
disagreeable man,
but you want them to be tamable.
So it means, you don't want
him to be so disagreeable,
he can't be generous
and caring and share,
but you don't want
him to be so agreeable
that a psychopath
can take him out.
And I mean, this is
a technical issue.
Because, so you might say...
So, Noah also talked
about what happened in
one of these cities
that set up one of those
sort of autonomous zones.
The mayor, I think it was,
I can't remember the city.
- Probably Seattle, was chop.
- I think, yeah, it was Seattle,
you're exactly right.
And the mayor said
something like,
"Well, maybe it'll be sort
of like a Summer of Love."
It's like, yeah maybe.
But we remember how the Summer
of Love ended by the way.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Hell's
Angels Biker Gangs
at the Rolling Stones concert.
So, anyways,
Summer of Love.
Okay, so everybody's agreeable
and they're getting
along and they're
handing out food, which
isn't free by the way,
but is free in the states
because we're so efficient,
essentially.
It's all Summer of Love stuff.
Yeah, but what the psychopaths,
well, when did they come out?
How about at night?
So this is naive beyond belief.
And there are computer
models of this,
so if you set up communities
of hyper agreeable people,
all they do is share and their
days' growing out of their...
Or if it says,
"What happens?
You throw one shark in the
water and everyone gets eaten."
Okay, so women have
this tough problem
'cause they have to
protect their infants,
and they can't really do
it 'cause they're smaller,
and they're concerned
with their infants,
they're occupied.
They need men to guard them.
Well, that means they
need men who can be guards
so that they have to pay
a price in agreeableness,
the women do.
And some times I've
seen couples where
the man is just so masculine,
and the woman's so feminine
that they can't
even communicate.
They're like from
different planets,
Mars and Venus.
They just can't bridge the gap.
And so this is a really
tough evolutionary problem.
It's like you have
to have generosity,
you have to have toughness
because you gotta keep down
the cheaters and the miscreants.
They have to be
held under control,
and you're naive to think
that that's not the case.
Psychopaths, by the way,
psychopaths vary in
the general population
between about one and 5%
and seem to stabilize
it about 3%.
And so that's also
a big critique
of the leftist notion that
hierarchies are
nothing but power.
Because if that was
true, psychopaths would
be much more prevalent
than they are way
more successful.
And what happens is
once the psychopaths
get past a certain
percentage of the population,
people wake up to them, and
the tough guys stop them.
And like, is that really
surprising to anyone?
It's like the tough
policemen, stop them,
the tough military
guys, stop them.
There's no such
thing as tough guys.
And isn't it, the kid
that they're actually
tougher than tough women.
And so what are
we children here?
Or are we gonna look at this
straightforwardly and clearly.
- Yeah, and that is what it
so much of this seems
to boil down to me
that we just seem to be
afraid to confront these.
What I don't think
are actually that,
it's not that they're
not complex issues,
but they're things that
we used to talk about.
Honestly, I mean, you know
how frustrated I've been
with a lot of the sort
of liberal intelligentsia
that in many ways
I think ushered
so much of this in that is in-
- Yeah, well, I'm-
- now saying, "Oh, now
we've got a problem."
But it's like, "Guys."
- Yeah, well, I'm still
appalled at the faculty.
And what I saw happening
when I was a faculty member,
I retired this year.
In some sense I'm teaching
like hundreds of
thousands of people now
instead of hundreds, and so
that seems like a better idea.
But what I saw the
faculty do in my career,
not at Harvard the way,
was continually seed territory
to the administration,
one cowardly decision at a time,
one cowardly micro
decision at a time,
and I really think that's
the sin of the left,
the moderate left.
It's cowardly retreats
on micro issues.
The sin on the right is probably
the right has bigger sins,
and they're more obvious
and they're sort of
clumped together.
So, but the left it's like
this continual retreat.
So first of all, the
faculty retreated
and the administration
took over,
which was a really bad idea.
I used to fight with
my faculty members
at the University of Toronto.
The administration would
do something arbitrary,
like say, "Well, how about
your third year seminars,
fourth year seminars have
30 people in them
instead of 15."
Oh it's like, "Well then
they're not a seminar."
So then I say, "Well
how about we just say,
'No, hire more faculty.'"
Just, "No, we will not do that."
Well,
they would've capitulated
instantly the administration,
if we would've said no for sure.
But they never said no.
And I said, "Well,
why won't you say no?"
"Well, they won't give
us what we want then."
"Well, they don't give you
what you want anyways."
I saw an endless number
of five year plans
come and go where
nothing that was promised
was ever delivered.
I'm not being
cynical about this,
I mean the University of Toronto
ran pretty reasonably for
a overgrown and heavily
bureaucratized institution.
So it was all these
retreats while then these
insane ideas came in.
And here's the fundamental idea.
And it really deals
with the mystery,
I'm writing this new
book about it called
"We Who Wrestle with God."
We don't know how
we manage the act of perception.
We actually don't know,
it's really complicated.
That's why we don't have
general per purpose robots,
is because perceiving
the world turns out to be
way more complicated than
anybody ever imagined.
'Cause we kind of think,
"Well, there's objects out
there and you just see them."
It's like, if you take
a picture of a landscape
and you put it in Photoshop
and then you blow it up,
you can't tell where the
lines are between the objects.
Well, the real world
is kind of like that.
and even defining
simple things is like,
What's a table?
Well, it's a flat
surface with four legs.
Well, okay, is a
dollhouse table, a table?
How about if you put a
plate full of food on a
stump and sit down to it,
is that a table?
What if the stump is
actually kind of slanted?
What if it has a soft surface?
Like maybe you put a
plate on a bean bag,
is that now a table?
Well, if a table might not be
a flat surface with four
legs or one leg or three legs
or a triangular surface,
it might be a place you
put a plate full of food on
to it down in eat at, which
is a functional definition.
And it turns out that
most of the things we see
are actually functional
icons rather than objects.
And then you can't get
a machine to see that
because they're not embodied.
In any case, the
mystery of perception,
how do we categorize?
It's a great mystery,
and the answer the left
lept to in the face of
this immense mystery,
which is how can finite
creatures comprehend the
infinite well
enough to function?
That's the mystery.
Their answer was,
"Well, all our categories
are based on the
expression of will to power."
And that's actually partly true,
because part of our motivation
is move up hierarchies,
but that can be
based on competence,
and all of our
institutions are corrupted
by power and deceit.
So if they would've said,
"Part of our categorization
is will to power."
No problem, it would
left a mystery open.
And this is a huge mystery,
it's a religious mystery in
the final analysis, I believe.
And if you have faith, you
believe that it's something like
the spirit of goodness itself
that does categorization,
that lays out our
basic perceptions.
And that would depend
on your motivation,
so we could say like,
if you were oriented
in the highest manner
you could be oriented,
then the contents of
your categories would be
subservient to the good.
And I think you have
to be immensely cynical
to think that will to power
is a more powerful
force than that.
And that sort of cynicism
that devours the world,
and so we don't wanna do that.
And I can see why the
universities fell into that
because I think this was the
biggest mystery that emerged
philosophically in the last
half of the 20th century.
It's like, "Oh my."...
See, 'cause what happened on.
in the English
Departments it was...
Well, we don't know
how we perceive even
a simple landscape.
Okay, well how about a text?
Oh, well wait a minute.
How many ways can
you interpret a text?
Oh, a near infinite
number of ways.
This is true, technically.
A near infinite number of ways.
Well, okay, which of those
interpretations
should take priority?
Well,
we don't know how
we figure that out.
And so well how do we know
it's not just the naked
expression of power?
Well, sometimes it is,
and that that's the idea,
it's like, this is a problem.
Now it's the wrong
solution because
it isn't, the naked will to...
The fundamental human motivation
is not the naked will to power.
Here's the fundamental
human motivation,
it's...
I'll tell you a quick
story, if you don't mind,
hopefully it'll be quick.
I went to see Die Meistersinger
in New York, the Opera.
Okay, so it's very
cool, this Opera,
I'm gonna write about it
in detail in this book.
But here's the basic story.
There's a town called Nurnberg,
and there's a bunch
of guilds in the town.
Trek, craftsman,
cobblers
like blacksmiths,
guys who work, who
make things, right?
So they're glued
right to the bottom,
they know how to wire
the electrical outlet.
Now they've all organized
together and elected
a master singer in each guild.
So the head of the guild,
isn't one of the craftsman,
although he is a craftsman,
he also has to be a singer.
Okay, now all these guild guys
get together, the singers,
and they elect each new singer.
And so the story
is set up so that
a new singer is going
to be elected and
one of the craftsman singers.
says he'll stake his entire
fortune and his daughter
on this new contest.
He'll award his daughter
to the new master singer.
Although she has a choice,
she doesn't have to
do it by the way.
So this isn't like
patriarchal oppression,
it's a father trying to
offer his daughter the best
after judicious consideration.
Fully cognizant of the
fact that he loves her and
allowing her choice,
encouraging her choice.
A Knight comes in,
who's wandered around
in the natural world,
and he's such a
great singer that
they can't help, but
recognize his talent,
but he breaks all the rules,
and the girl falls
in love with him.
Okay, so,
this guy who puts up
his fortune, he says,
"'Cause people have criticized
me for only pursuing money,
I'm willing to
subordinate my fortune
to the pursuit of
this highest art.
And I'll put my daughter
on the line too."
It's like, this is real.
Okay, so the rest...
Now, so the man all get
together in these guilds
and they try to
elect the top figure,
and this guy's name is...
All right, the next thing
that happens is that
the guilds degenerate
into competition
because they're all
fighting for this girl.
And that's what
happens among men.
It's like they do get together,
they do elect someone
whose highest amongst them,
and then the
highest get together
and elect what is highest yet.
That's what unites
us, that's real.
And we do fragment
because of competition.
So that can fall apart.
Anyways, the opera is
a masterful exploration
of all of that.
But it isn't will to power that
is at the basis
of categorization.
It's something like respect
for the divine word,
and that's indistinguishable
from truth.
And that's set against
the will of power,
and it's way more...
Try it out from your own life.
Do things for power,
see what happens,
that's hell.
'Cause even if you
get what you want,
by the time you get it,
you'll be a psychopath.
No love, nothing.
Just corruption
everywhere around you.
Truth, that's a whole
different thing.
And we're so powerful now,
we better tell the truth.
We could have paradise
laid out in front of us,
if we're careful or we
could let everything burn.
- Do you think you've
made way on this?
When you've talked, I
watched just about a week ago
with your chat with Steven
Pinker and Jonathan Haidt,
two guys who I hold
in the highest like
intellectual regard.
I've had them on the show,
I like them both very much.
They come from the more
atheist perspective on this,
we've talked about
this a million times.
- Yeah, so they think.
- Right, okay, so that's it.
- That's not, I'm
going to Cambridge-
- That's where your
argument is that that-
- I'm going Cambridge and
Oxford to talk about this,
in detail, what I just laid out.
'Cause what I wanna do is,
especially when I go to the UK
in these conversations
is I wanna
lay out a technical
argument for sacred depth.
So imagine this,
we have a intuition that
there's depth in literature
'cause we think, well
that's a shallow story,
and that's a deep
story and we think,
"Well that was really
compelling and gripping.
It hit me at a
profound level, right?"
Versus, "Well, that was
just light entertainment."
Light, right?
We all have those intuitions.
So what is this depth, and
how far to down does it go?
Well, it goes down to
the bottom of things.
What's at the bottom?
Well what's at the bottom
is by definition, religious.
And why would I say that?
Well it's because when things
move you at that level,
that's how you experience it.
It's not thought,
it's way deeper.
So it's like,
I go out with my dock at
night, up north where I am now,
and it's dark and the
expanse of the heavens
is laid out above me.
And I look up, well, I'm not
thinking religious thoughts,
I'm confronting the
infinite itself,
and that moves you inside.
And I would say it even
moves you to imitation,
because you know what it means
to have your head
in the stars, right?
I mean, it means
to be oriented up
in the highest possible manner.
And so we're so compelled
to imitate again
at an instinctual level
that we can even imitate
the infinite that we see spread
above us in the night sky.
And that's a religious calling.
And all this talk about
whether you believe in God,
and it's all propositionalised.
It's like, well it's
it misses the point.
That's why I don't ever
answer when people say,
"Do you believe in God?"
I say, "What do you
mean by believe?"
And they think, "Well,
you know what I mean?"
It's like, "No, you
don't know what you mean,
you have a bunch of assumptions
that you don't even recognize
that you're peppering
the question with
to force me into
a box to deliver
the kind, answer that
your question demands
given the way you phrased it."
It's like, "No,
you say you don't believe in
God, well God is ineffable."
What do you mean you
don't believe in God?
Well what do you believe
in then, nothing?
Well, no.
Everything?
Well, no that doesn't work
'cause then you're chaotic.
Well what's your highest value,
diversity, equity, inclusivity?
Well, I don't need
a highest value.
Well yes you do 'cause
otherwise nothing orients you
through the
landscape of choices.
This isn't optional.
- So to give the
devil his due, then,
- Yeah.
- when you've had
the conversations
with a lot of these guys
you just talked to Sam Harris
again also, all of these guys.
- Yeah, that went
great by the way.
- At the end
people that are not
necessarily believers,
your basic argument, I'm
doing a little 101 here,
is that you're a believer
whether you believe it or not,
that you're being driven-
- Well, Harris...
- Yeah.
- Okay, let's take
Harris is a good example.
Harris does not believe in God,
but he believes in the devil.
So he's halfway there.
And why do I say he
believes in the devil?
- I think he believes
Trump is the devil.
Yeah.
- Yeah, okay.
But that's a mistake.
He also believes
religion is the devil,
and that's also a mistake.
- Yeah.
- So what do I mean
when I say that
he believes in the devil?
Well, all I did the last
time I talked to Sam
was asking for questions.
That was a way bit...
And I that's something I
highly recommend as a strategy.
Just find out from the
person you're talking to
what they think.
And don't try to win,
try to learn.
- Well, so Sam is
really motivated
by the same thing that
motivated me, 30 years ago.
He looked at the panoply
of human atrocity,
it terrified him
right to the core.
It's like, well,
anything but this.
And he wants something like
an objective standard of values.
Now he thinks it can
be found in science.
I think that's
technically wrong,
but it's an argument
worth having,
and we don't know
how to sort out
the relationship between
science and values.
But the thing is, is that Sam
certainly believes in evil.
Okay, well, if you
believe in evil,
you also believe in good,
because good is the opposite
of evil, whatever that is.
And well what's God?
Well, God is what's good.
Well, okay, what does that mean?
Is he a spirit?
Is he a spirit in the sky?
What do you mean by spirit?
So here's something
to think about,
this is what I think.
When I look back at the good men
that I've been fortunate
enough to know in my life,
there's a spirit that
shines through each of them.
That makes them good,
that's how I can tell
that each of them is good.
Well, the essence of that good,
that's no different than God,
it might even be God.
Now you say, "Well, what
does that mean, that spirit."
Well it's whatever is common
among good men, let's say,
was that real?
Or isn't, what's
common among things
more real than what's different?
And why a spirit?
Well, it animates them,
it's an animating force.
It's not a disbar abstraction,
which is the problem
with conceptions of God
like Einstein's conception,
it's so disembodied, it has
no connection to the world.
And that causes the death
of God, that abstraction.
Mircea Eliade
documented deaths of God
in many cultures across history.
It's not only
something that happened
in the West that NCHE announced.
And it happens when
the idea of God
gets so abstracted
that it no longer has any
connection with the world.
Well, and those are the
things I'm gonna talk about
at Cambridge and Oxford,
and I'm gonna talk
to Richard Dawkins.
So that's so cool because,
I'd like to ask
him some questions.
'Cause Dawkins is smart,
and he's put forward
maybe the most coherent,
biologically oriented
argument for
clockwork determinism,
something like that.
- Well, Jordan, I mean,
I have to tell you,
this is what...
I mean, I know you know this,
but when we were on tour,
I think the thing
that you changed me on
more than anything else
I talk about in my book,
they were two things.
It was the importance
of being a parent,
because you would always say,
"Most people to live a
fully actualized life,
have to go through
that experience,
there are some exceptions,
but most people."
But the other one was
connecting to belief,
and I think what
changed me on this was
watching you do these lectures
every night, saying the truth
saying, "I'm just saying
what I believe to be true
and trying to take my thoughts
to the end and then
I'll explore them
further the next night."
But then seeing
that translate into
real world change for people,
the literally thousands
of people who had
unbelievable stories
about the terrors
that they had been through
that had turned
their lives around.
And I thought that that
is the higher good,
that is God, that it's,
we can do the whole
definition game and all that.
But that you, especially
at the peak of that thing,
were expressing something that
was so profoundly true
that we all know
that maybe we can't
exactly get into the box,
that we can just hand
to somebody and say,
"This is it."
But that was enough to move me.
I think that's
really the argument
you're trying to make that
you'll bring to
Cambridge and Oxford,
and to Dawkins and
everybody else.
- Yeah, well, and I would
say in your situation,
I know you're
contemplating fatherhood,
and it's probably
the right spirit to
inhabit you as a
political commentator,
let's say a cultural
commentator.
That's a good way
to, re-construe it.
To the degree that you can be,
'cause you're getting
old enough now too,
that's the right role.
You're not sort of upward
striving hero youth,
you're in that transition.
And like benevolent father
that's a good one, man.
And there's no short,
there's no limit to
the number of people
you can bring that to.
And there's no limit to
how much good that'll do
in your own life and
in relationship to
your own children.
- I know you gotta go here,
so let me just ask
you one other thing
just to tie all
of this together.
Now looking back at
these last couple years,
the intellectual
pursuits, obviously,
your health is better
at least to some degree,
you're getting back
out on the road,
you're gonna start touring
and all of this stuff.
Do you feel that this is
all really making a dent?
Do you feel like-
- Yes, definitely.
- that it's heavy and it's
real and doing something?
- Yeah, it's more real
than anything else.
I don't mean what I'm
doing specifically.
- Yeah.
- But the sorts of things
that we've been talking about,
I think the will
to power just folds
in its presence.
It's so much more powerful.
Well how can it not be if
it's actually the truth?
How can it not be more
powerful than falsehood?
How can what isn't there
be more powerful
than what is there?
And wouldn't we
wanna align ourselves
with the truth?
It's really painful
in the short-term,
'cause there's so much
mess you have to clear up,
your own and historical
mess even for that matter.
But it's better than
living in filth,
and so onward and upward.
Yes, and I'm optimistic man
and I've seen great
people in your country
on both sides of the
political spectrum,
striving with all their might
to bring things away
from the insane edges.
Don't lose faith,
don't lose faith in
your institutions,
they're great institutions,
they're great institutions
fundamentally.
And remember
everyone could
have enough to eat,
have enough energy,
everyone can have an
opportunity for their children.
All of that.
We have all of that
in front of us,
we have it right now, we
have it in the next 20 years.
If we don't
get suspicious and paranoid
and power mad and
especially deceitful
- Jordan, I will
do the best I can.
Actually, no.
I'll try to do a little
better than the best I can.
How about that?
- Yeah, well, that
wouldn't be lovely?
- It was good seeing my friend.
- Good to see you, Dave.
- If you'd like
to see more honest
and insightful
conversations with
Jordan Peterson himself,
check out our Jordan
Peterson playlist,
which includes every interview
I've ever done with him.
And if you wanna watch full
reviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist
both are right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.